uh somebody who you had as a mentor
which not a lot of people can say is uh
rest in peace to prince prince who's one
of the greatest creators of all time
quite possibly the most talented
musician ever he's up there in terms of
just the guitar he could do it all how
did you guys initially connect well he
um is always the story just still freaks
me out and that freaks me out but just I
can't even believe
that it happened but he was supposed to
show up I was open opening up for
Raphael Sadiq this is yeah exactly my
first album and um
I get a knock after I get finished
performing and
you know I had this argument I had a
sinus infection that day I was just like
loopy and
this uh really really pretty girl knocks
on the door and she was like I have
somebody who wants to talk to you and
the girl was DJ Rashida who was Princess
DJ at the time but I didn't know that
that was right you know his DJ and she
just gives me the phone and then I'm
like hello and I'm like congested and
just like hello and he's like hello
Janelle
did you know right away and I'm like hi
who is this
this is Prince
Prince
yeah Prince I was supposed to come to
your gig but they gave me the wrong time
and I'm like
what like just freaking out or trying
not to because I don't want to embarrass
myself and so then he proceeds to say
listen I was supposed to come we're
having a jam session you know do you and
the band want to come back and you know
jam and I was like yeah we want to come
back and jam and
the rest was history the rest was this
on the Minneapolis tour tour no he was
in LA oh so what he would do is and he
was one of the best like party throwers
that you will ever know I mean we have
seen uh some Chappelle skits that
I mean I don't know how true those kids
are right but my interactions with him
have always been like
can play guitar and party like
till the sun comes up seven in the
morning I didn't leave that night me and
my band we did not leave till seven in
the morning so this was a jam session oh
wow seven in the morning it was it was
just it was amazing and he was just
talking to me he was like he was telling
me everything he loved about what he had
seen me do and I was like I didn't even
know you looked on the internet right
like you know who I am that's wild I'm
just like I would just think you would
be somewhere
yeah in in some sort of Castle right you
know with no Wi-Fi right with no Wi-Fi
but he was very aware and I always tell
people the best thing about him is like
even though he was mysterious he never
let his mystery get in the way of his
mentorship he was always like wanting to
give advice and you know open up if you
have any questions about the business
and didn't even charge me anything to be
on my album give me the most about you
have three pretty serious mentors Prince
Puff Daddy Big Boy give me three lessons
each of them
wow
um
Prince is like obviously like the
blueprint for
um
you know owning your you know
like as an artist not being afraid to
fight for what you were old on the
business side of things right
um and also creating a blueprint
um
that fell so free and
you could do anything you know and just
and just also speaking with him
he just always reminded me that
musically there was nothing that I could
not do
and I think with puff
who has been a person of his word
um you know we have a partnership
together when he had first heard me and
doing the science fiction singing about
that and you know
doing doing whatever I wanted to do as
an artist creatively he always said like
I don't want to mess that up right I
just want the rest of the world to see
what I saw when I just saw tonight I
just want to help so I called him at a
really good time and
um you know he's just always been an
advocate for for me if I need to have
like
any business conversations I can I know
I can call him and you know listen to
him as well and then he just taught me
to just like be a fan of your own [__]
too you know promote your stuff if you
love it you got to promote your [__]
yeah yeah you worked hard and I think
with big boy big boy was just I mean I
got to give it to him you know the
reason why puffy even knew about me was
because of the work
that big boy gave to me I was thinking
back up I was also on Idlewild you know
he was really really promoting me with
purple ribbon he taught me the
importance of I think staying with
family like screaming with the people
for like a little little bit Yeah my lip
but I always had my label but I would do
Partnerships yeah it was you was it was
a Bubba spark yes
[Laughter]
look at you a lot of people do not
remember killing my killer
Mike's new album which is coming out is
it that one is it it's not out yet okay
I listened to it a couple weeks ago okay
it's incredible one of the greatest
rappers of all time oh I gotta I gotta
listen to it yeah it's incredible